so this is kind of an impromptu talk
that i decided needed to happen because
i see really inaccessible
stuff on the web all the time
and just this last week i saw a website
that was very popular
and i decided that
because it was popular but it was
inaccessible it was worth talking about
it a little more so i'm going to talk
about keyboard accessibility
and i'm marcy sutton i'm a developer at
substantial in seattle which is a 60-ish
person product development studio
and i build websites and mobile apps
there it's not really an accessibility
shop but i add accessibility to all of
my projects whenever i can
so
out of any of us have any of us
broken an arm before have you ever
broken your arm
have you ever run out of batteries in
your mouth and had to use your keyboard
all right
so you have a reason maybe that you
can't use a mouse what about if you're
vision impaired or blind
i mean you guys are looking around the
room so it doesn't seem likely but maybe
you know somebody that is
all of a sudden you find that you can't
use the mouse and it really sucks when
somebody hasn't taken the time to
enable the keyboard
it doesn't have to be that way either we
can make things accessible with a little
bit of effort so
because this is an impromptu talk
i'm just going to do some demos and we
can see what happens
so the first demo i want to do is of
whitehouse.gov
it's actually
it has some alternative text in it it's
not the worst for accessibility but for
keyboards it's pretty awful
when i first looked at this site
i was using a mouse so i could go around
the website and see these
big hover menus
but if i start tabbing through the
website
i get a dotted outline around the logo
and some visual feedback but not much
and then i get lost i don't know where i
am
i can look down at the status bar and
see that the url is changing but i have
no visual feedback
if i go back into the menu
where am i i don't even know where i am
video i happen to know that the video
link is in the photos and video
tab of the hover menu
all they had to do was enable this menu
from the keyboard it might have taken
some css
or it would definitely be some css it
might have taken a little bit of
javascript but it's really not rocket
science to make this work with the
keyboard
that's one pretty simple example
that there's no reason for it
like you could make that work a lot
better
so i mentioned a website that people
have been talking about a lot that
they were all oh wow look at how they
streamlined the work the workflow to buy
a plane ticket compared to united.com
it's you know so many screens less to
make it through this workflow but
the website is not accessible
it's pretty bad so it's virgin america
it's their beta website i get that it's
a beta site i don't want to be too harsh
on them because i know that things are a
work in progress but given all of the
polish and the yay we made it more fun
to navigate but then the blatant
disregard for a keyboard or a screen
reader is really unfortunate
so when i first looked at the site
i started tabbing around the page
and again i see the status bar changing
at the bottom but i have no visual
feedback i have no idea what's going on
here
if i hover i get some feedback but
nothing if you want to use a keyboard at
all
and so
it's really a bummer
when i test a website like this i have a
couple different tools
see can we hear that i turn on voiceover
on my mac just by hitting command f5 you
are currently on a link inside of a list
to click this link press ctrl option
space so i can test it with a screen
reader to see what does what would a
blind person get
so i'm going to reload the page
so
i can see some visual feedback but if
i'm really using voiceover
if i'm using voiceover right it doesn't
matter if i can see it um so i'm just
going to start tabbing
link virgin america
okay they put some text there even
though it's like an image logo that's
good link book list three items okay so
they've got some text i'm gonna keep
tabbing
link link link link feed link
link flight alerts
link about elevate
link sign in link sign up link san
francisco
okay hold on there were there were
buttons there there were these radio
buttons right
inside html
how come i can't get to those press
control option space
if i click one of those buttons it
actually
you can use the mouse but you can't use
the keyboard
no you can't like nothing on here can
receive focus it's a real
one
bummer
ah so when i use the mouse to get the
focus there then all of a sudden i can
get to it but who's gonna do that
currently on a text element inside of a
list multi-city
san francisco link list six items boston
ma boss link
so sometimes voiceover reads things out
a little funny
but we we can see what they mean inside
of a list to click this link press
control option space actions menu two
items oh i'm a voice over newbie i don't
use it all the time
so you can use voiceover on your mac on
your iphone you can also
install virtualbox on a mac and then you
have access to internet explorer which
you can use jaws which is a the most
widely used screen reader you can
actually get a
demo version that's free of jaws i
didn't know that until recently it's a
really good testing tool you can use it
for 40 minutes at a time unrestricted
and it's really good way to test the
most widely used screen reader you can
also get firefox obviously on any
platform but you can get mvda
for free on
for windows which you can use through
virtualbox those are a few of the tools
that i use to test these things but as
far as keyboard access goes
with the virgin america site i just
started tabbing through it and i could
see that it had a
blatant disregard for focus styles
and table elements so
being a
curious developer i opened the dev tools
just to see
what what kind of code did they use here
so if i go back to the home page here
it is an angular app
which
you know on its own it's not angular's
fault but it's inaccessible it's just
really unfortunate that they
didn't
make things work
from the keyboard so some of these items
that that i couldn't focus on i want to
see what those are made of
so there's actually an anchor in here
it's
maybe not the most semantic element for
it to be an anchor if it has an empty
href value but i'll grant them at least
it has text in it but since i can't tab
onto the thing it's a real bummer
i actually i think you can tab onto it
you just don't get any visual feedback
so you you don't know
which element you're on which there's
actually
you could argue that screen reader usage
is a smaller number of your overall
audience but
keyboard usage is huge
and i think the only reason that we
don't do it more is because the
experience sucks and we can give up so
we do
so
for the virgin america website all they
really had to do was define the
focus style along with the hover style
and they didn't do that and it's super
easy to do
so um
you can easily find this stuff out just
by opening the dev tools and tabbing
through a webpage and see what kind of
an experience you get
so
i'm going to go back to my little slides
here
so that's a bummer right people are
launching these beautiful sites they get
all this fanfare like woohoo it's a
shorter workflow to buying a plane
ticket
unless you're on a keyboard or screen
reader and that's a huge bummer
but there are some websites that do it a
little better
nothing's perfect but
one that i like a lot
and i'll admit i'm a little biased
because i worked on it
but target's corporate website
everything that they build has to be
accessible and so
this was a really fun project to get to
take a beautiful brand and make
something really interactive and
accessible
so
for this site
there were some really key features i
wanted to add including skip links so i
can jump to major parts of it so for
this we have three skip links
i'm going to go to the the main
navigation
and i can skip right by unlike the white
house website where we tabbed on the
main nav items and we were forced
through all of those off-screen links
in this case i skip right on by even
though if i hit enter it expands and it
shows me more items and then i can tab
in
so from a keyboard keyboard or screen
reader experience
i am basically creating a one-to-one
whether you're using the mouse or the
keyboard so if i have the mouse i can
hover over and then if i want to pin it
then it works on a tablet
it works on a desktop with a keyboard or
a mouse
and i even wired up the escape key which
is really awesome so that anytime you're
you have something open
you can just hit escape and get out of
it
so if i go back to our skip links
now i'm jump down into the content and i
can start tabbing around
and these tiles were really cool too
because i can tab onto them hit enter it
flips onto the back side and then i can
go to this link
otherwise
if that was
off screen because the the tile isn't
flipped yet
i don't want to be forced onto some link
that i can't see because then i have no
idea what it goes to in this case i can
flip the tile
then i get to the back side of it and if
it has a link
then i can go to it so that's pretty
cool
so i can go to that link
so this this website was a really good
opportunity to
keep the design appeal up and not have
to
compromise too much for the sake of
accessibility
and i think we can
we can create really interesting ui
patterns and not have to sacrifice
access
so
one other example that i've been working
on recently
and this is a really fun app to work on
it's called distiller and it's actually
a whiskey recommendation engine
and when i got onto this project
it's not that it wasn't supposed to be
accessible or that people didn't
want it to be it's that they just didn't
know any better and i think that's the
case for a lot of websites is that we
tend to develop for ourselves and we
don't really remember that there's
people who can't see
or can't use a mouse
so for the whiskey site distiller
i really wanted to make it accessible
because how cool is it to go and have a
shelf of your own your favorite whiskies
online i think that's pretty cool and i
have blind friends who think that's
pretty cool
we have a feature we'd love to add i
don't know logistically how or when this
will happen but getting whiskey
delivered to your house would be pretty
fantastic especially if you are blind
and you can't go to the store
like heck yeah i think a lot of people
could see the appeal of that
so for distiller we actually added
a feature where you can reorder the
bottles on your top shelf and it's a
drag and drop feature
i'm actually going to open the version
of it on my machine because
i don't think it's been deployed yet
so when i started working on this
oh and my uh my local host content is
not whiskey related
um
but this had a mouse only drag and drop
feature and i thought it would be really
important to make that accessible i
asked around a few friends and making
drag and drop accessible is a
non-trivial task i actually don't even
know how you would do that
so i just kind of
reused some of the same functionality
but enabled it with the keyboard so in
this case i added some skip links which
we have in the top left corner i think
those are the ones that haven't been
deployed yet but it jumps you into the
content
i want to jump you farther into the
content because i still have these links
on the left side that i need to tab
through
but these were not accessible at all
before like i think you could tab onto
them but they didn't have
any visual feedback so you had no idea
where you were
so now
i have a list of three bottles on my top
shelf and if i want to reorder them
the way that i would do it before is i
would click this button that says
reorder bottles and i get a little
draggable
icon like a in this case we're using the
hamburger icon to tell you that you can
move it
and we're using a little jquery sortable
plugin
every time that you
drag something on your list it actually
rips out the dom and then replaces it
and so your focus is lost that's
something that i'm doing a lot of
research on with javascript mvcs right
now because this is a pretty widespread
problem it's not unique to this website
i think the virgin america angular site
probably had similar
problems i didn't even have to dive in
that far to find problems but
in this case
something that we'd implemented it
needed help and that's okay it's
something that we can improve so
for this i made it so you can tab onto
the button which was a big improvement
and you can hit enter on it and because
it was ripping the button out too you
would lose focus so it now it sends you
back onto the button
and i can toggle it to turn this edit
mode on and off
so now i can tab on the list
and i actually get feedback that tells
me which item i'm on and it makes it
actually usable
so if i use the arrow keys i can reorder
it
and in a screen reader
voice over on chrome profile vertical
line distiller window bottle two of
three bushmills two one-year-old use
arrows to reorder button as keyboard
focus so i added links or text off
screen to tell you where it is
bottle one of three bushmills two
one-year-old use arrows to reorder
button lists five items so when it
reorders
it actually updates the number that's
off screen so it'll dynamically count
how many there are and then right now i
have three out of five
it will
out of how many bottles you have on your
top shelf right now it will count them
up put the number in and then for
whichever item that what whatever index
that is in the list it will update it as
you move the list without that you don't
have enough context to know
what the heck is this thing and how do i
move it i don't know
like what number is it i mean we would
go through all this trouble to make this
list resortable with the arrows and
you'd have no reason why you probably
wouldn't even use it
so
this is one feature that i i really got
to hammer on and improve the
accessibility of and i think it turned
out pretty good there's a lot more work
we have to do to this app because of the
way that the dom gets ripped out and
re-rendered
like some pages you aren't notified when
the page changes like say i go to my
collection
um at least in voiceover
i'll do that again expert whiskey
recommendations vertical line distiller
window two items marcy sutton profile
accessibility is rad share collection
there's open space on your collection
want some ideas get a recommendation
link search for whiskey link group has
keyboard focus
so it doesn't actually tell me when the
page changes when i click to a tab
you are currently on a group inside of
html content to enter no ideas in this
group press control option shift down
arrow what i did do on the other hand
though that that's part of the way there
visited link cert visited link
visit visited
visited link sign out visited link my
top shelf lists two items
visited link my collection current page
the thing i did that got it part of the
way there
is making it say current page so i have
some visual feedback that tells me it's
like that's the current thing but
otherwise i have no idea so i added text
off screen that changes when you change
the page in voiceover it doesn't tell me
when the page changes so that's
something i'd like to add but in jaws on
internet explorer on windows it actually
does pick up the change and that's the
most widely used screen reader so
that's pretty cool i was happy to find
that out it was actually a really smooth
experience
i can actually show that
what that looks like
so virtualbox is a free vm that you can
download and you can get all these
different versions
i have an ie 11 version
and with that you can go and grab any
browser
um like i said earlier the free demo
version of jaws
is a really sweet way to test the stuff
so jaws
original blend bottle
actually this is nvda back toggle
favorites
i'm gonna go kill that
out of that notification overflow this
one reads everything as you hover on it
running at bushmills 21 year old running
app no no no nvda
yes quit
so
i can open jaws just like a normal
application it's an application that
runs on top of a screen reader which is
super interesting like when i first got
into accessibility i had some there was
some mystery about what jaws is
how it works
i actually didn't know they had a free
demo version until a few months ago
and it's unrestricted you can use it for
40 minutes at a time
nope doesn't want to let me open it
come on jaws hook us up
jf jaws dialogue okay button let's
reboot sorry guys
all right well i think that experiment
maybe not going to work
profile distiller internet explorer
button tool tip i should have planned
that a little better
well one thing that
we could do
is go back to
either distiller or
um there's actually more to the virgin
america site that i thought was really
interesting so i would turn voiceover
voiceover on last night and started
navigating to see what beyond just the
keyboard stuff what would happen
chrome virgin america window virgin
america html content has keyboard focus
so i'm just going to like close my eyes
and try to use this thing and see what
happens
virgin america
link linked link i happen to know where
the stuff is
link flying with us
link where we fly
link fees
link flight status
link flight alerts
link link
visited link link san francisco okay i'd
like to go to san francisco
you are currently on a link inside of
html content okay so the
page option space i'm on a new page i
happen to know because i could see it
but i had no idea that the page changed
so that's the problem i was talking
about with distiller that we don't know
when the page changes
so we need a little bit of help to
notify the user
so say i pick a city
no idea and get any feedback
maybe i want to go to portland
there was a notification at the top of
the screen that said something and i
don't know what that is
so actually i handled that in distiller
just this last week two items marcy
sutton profile accessibility is rad
share collection there's open space on
your collection want some ideas get a
recommendation link search for whiskey
link group
so i'm going to sign out and i'll get a
similar notification
expert whiskey recommendations vertical
line distiller html content 41
4. you are now signed out
all right so that's something that they
could do on that site to make that
better
and the technique that i used is called
aria live regions
this isn't so much css related but it's
a really basic html thing that you can
do where you basically
you're watching an element and if you
put arya live and then an attribute in
this case i put
assertive and that says hey whatever
you're reading this is the most
important thing and it actually had a
property called rude before because it's
supposed to be rude like hey stop what
you're doing read this thing and in the
case of an alert box
something that needs to be read right
away that's useful
so actually we can go and inspect that
in distiller and see what it looks like
so
in this case
here we have a div that says aria live
assertive and it what that means is when
the page loads it's watching for changes
so all i have to do is append content
into it and it will read it
so let's do a little experiment
um i know i have jquery on this page so
i'm actually going to go look for it
aria live
assertive
okay so i have a hold of an
element going to get this prepped so
that it won't be hearing all the typing
and voice over
but
if i append
something to it
i really hope this works
voiceover on chrome expert whiskey
recommendations vertical line distiller
window dollar
expert whiskey recommendations vertical
line distiller htm group editable
expert whiskey recommendations vertical
line distiller html content
voice over off
well i don't think that worked and i
wonder why that's really interesting so
it actually has the content in the div
that i appended it to but it didn't read
it and i would argue that that's
probably a limitation of voice over
because i had a lot of trouble getting
that to work as well and i found
sometimes it was as buggy as leaving the
browser and coming back and then it
would work
so
that ended up
yeah being really challenging so i would
recommend
looking into aria live for these types
of applications
and that can improve notifying a user
when something is changing
because as we saw with this site um the
virgin america site not only did it have
a lot of keyboard access problems but
there's really a lack of notification so
it's really some user experience issues
do you guys have any questions
and the um that are present especially
when you start using keycodes
as
oh yeah um it so for that
so here i have the panel open
i
tend to put escape on the body so that
i'm always listening for it so that way
i could be
somewhere else like so the use case here
is the keyboard if i skip to the
navigation oh
navigation let me go back to the top i
went all the way to the footer
so if i go to the navigation and i'm on
this
nav
and then i keep going maybe
because if i click off it'll close it
but i'm anywhere on the document and i
hit escape
i want to be listening for it whereas if
i'm scoped to something in the nav with
jquery or some other way of binding that
event if i'm scoped in too far then i
won't actually
fire the event
and we like to use event delegation
anyway and
target elements in a different way
so
for for the escape key in particular i
like to scope to the body
i actually i had one other thing quickly
it sounds like we should wrap up but
um
i threw together a little
gist of the code i used for the
distiller
sorting
for the the top shelf stuff and for that
i made a really simple little javascript
object for
the key codes so that i could basically
put those really
magic numbers that like when you hit the
escape key
in the event object you get returned the
number the key code so rather than
having those sprinkled throughout my
code i put those all in one configurable
document and then i can just reference
it with like some variable name
that's one way to make that better
and then
i'm always listening to the escape key
and i can check which key code it was
because you're actually listening to any
key event
but you only want to do something if the
condition is right and those conditions
are was it the escape key
and am i on the right page
am i sorting
key process into somewhat more semantic
events and then trigger those
totally
yeah so for this on top shelf we listen
for the escape key and then we trigger
an event and that's an app level event
so
that way we are always firing the event
and then whether or not the listener is
bound and it will actually do something
about it
it makes it so that you don't have all
this logic buried in an event handler
you actually have it like moved into
some other easy to maintain place
and then this sortable list observer is
only dealing with like the guts of the
sortable list
and then it hands off the
like starting and stopping of the um
the disabled sorting event is actually
in a different object
yeah i guess
a good example of this would be
if you had like an input
text box
in that case you would probably want to
scope it using delegation like make sure
that you're actually on the right thing
like actually on this gist i have some
events bound here and i'm i'm listening
to the body but then i'm diving down
into anything that has a data behavior
of sort handle so that's agnostic to the
type of tag it just looks for the sort
handle which is only available after you
push the sorting button
because it rips the dom in and out it's
actually not even present but the event
is always listening and when that
condition is true then it will do stuff
yeah
cool so thanks for showing up
yeah
yeah so key press and key down there are
slight differences in which keys are
available so you have to do a little
monkeying around
cool thanks
you